[Music]
hi hi
what's your name Sydney lovely to meet
you oh they're Christmas
well you've got a lot of pressures
there's a whole list of questions going
on here but really that you must be
quite tired that's a long time to be
practicing okay tell me what's your
question good question Duffy I think his
heart was little because he was being
protective of his heart that was my
heart that's pretty good you wanna
listen listen you had to get a little
closer this it's not bad
Oh trust me it's beating away
[Music]
you got ax max I love Jo
[Music]
okay can I help
okay what do I do okay what about this
that way it's a hotel coffee this mine
I see we're doing it's very good thank
you
it's the Hat it's the house getting it
away Julie to help you do that there you
go there's some roofing god this looks
like brick Obama's house okay that's the
lightener done that oh yeah do you wanna
ask a question once we're doing this why
missin crack yeah it's a very good
question I just haven't eaten enough
today oh you mean is the Grinch okay
well um I am cranky because as the
Grinch he is somebody who finds
Christmas a little bit upsetting because
he's never had a nice one and he's a bit
fed up of the who's making it three
times bigger and louder and brighter and
jollier than before because it's
unavoidable and I think that's why the
Grinch is so it's a family favorite I
think you that we do you wanna put this
one on this side okay okay
block your oh there we go
we're in the middle of lost them and
we're just decorating a cake this
interview is done we're just with doing
things now I love Christmas
my favorite presence of free time of
being with my family and that's no word
of a lie what do you guys like about
Christmas okay
well that's that's part of it do you
like being with your with your family
and being off school and having fun
outside and seeing all the decorations
and singing songs yeah good good that's
a lot about what this film was about as
well as present sir they're fun but
they're not gingerbread houses on the
other hand it coming thinking fast into
the most important thing I've ever seen
in Christmas this is fantastic
hi you're watching you're watching Becca
day take your day with me better than
cover batch and Daphne and Sydney of
course sindhya Daphne here we have an
archetypal gingerbread house and
decorated beautifully by the girls and
yeah sit back and enjoy it what are you
doing getting high notes play oh my god
things could go horribly wrong from here
on in people she's eating the sugar
decorations
like what I'll be doing you say I hate
this gingerbread house it looks
disgustingly oh look at those colors
they're so pretty green and blue I love
it in red and oh so nice it looks like
yeah it's better to easier than to make
it isn't it Cheers eat sweets come back
to mummy dumpy
what's your favorite color blue the
other thing I was gonna say green you
don't mind or everybody said green did
they Daphne well sorry not definite your
name is we will get good at this one -
Cindy um green is is a good color it's
calming and not as tasty as why I say
[Laughter]
open your mouth your had a great
Christmas okay whose parenting is
parenting city because that's going to
be hours of fun good luck to you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]